Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
France, où va
ta diplomatie ?
On a souvent
fait reproche à la France d'avoir
une diplomatie en surplomb,
sous-entendu arrogante,
de chercher à parler
à tout le monde dans les conflits
qui parsèment la planète,
d'être toujours à la recherche
d'une influence stratégique
sinon politique
au sein de l'arène internationale.
Avec de grands succès
historiques, Talleyrand
et le congrès de Vienne,
de Gaulle et la France
parmi les grands
au sortir
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
plus proche de nous, en 2015,
la conférence sur le climat.
Mais aussi des échecs,
sinon des faux pas,
en Afrique, au Proche-Orient,
la Libye notamment,
au Maghreb, vis-à-vis
de Trump, Erdogan, Poutine,
qui ne se sont pas prêtés
aux sollicitations françaises.
Certes, cela n'incombe pas
exclusivement et exhaustivement
à la diplomatie,
mais au sein du concert des nations,
diplomatie et sécurité
sont souvent liées.
Il en est de même
avec le renseignement
et la militarisation
de la politique étrangère
des Etats-nations,
notamment lors des crises
et de cette guerre en Ukraine.
A cela il faut ajouter
que la scène diplomatique nationale
comme internationale doit
compter avec les ONG, parfois
très activistes, les intérêts
financiers bien souvent corrupteurs,
les empiètements
de l'espionnage informatique
et des lanceurs d'alerte.
Pour en venir à la France,
nous évoquerons également
les contraintes imposées
au corps diplomatique
et à cette espèce
de dichotomie stratégique
entre puissances moyennes,
auxquelles on nous classe,
et les hyper puissances
qui dominent l'économie mondiale
et tirent les ficelles
de la mondialisation.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Jérôme Bonnafont, que nous avons
en visioconférence
depuis Genève, qui est ambassadeur
auprès des Nations Unies
à Genève et des organisations
internationales en Suisse.
Yves Saint-Geours,
vous êtes ancien ambassadeur
au Brésil et en Espagne
et vous êtes président
du conseil d'administration
de l'Institut Pasteur.
Alain Rouquié, ancien ambassadeur,
président
de la Maison de l'Amérique latine.
Philippe Gélie,
mon confrère, qui est directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du Figaro
et, je crois, spécialiste
et en même temps responsable
de la politique internationale.
Alors, partons de cette pensée
du Général de Gaulle :
"Il faut prendre les choses
"comme elles sont,
car on ne fait pas
"de politique autrement
que sur des réalités."
La question
que je voudrais vous poser,
pour commencer ce débat,
c'est :
que peut la diplomatie française
face aux réalités du monde ?
Est-ce qu'elle vous paraît
bien orientée en termes d'adaptation
à la conflictualisation
de la planète ?
Jérôme Bonnafont, vous voulez
nous donner votre première
impression sur ce sujet ?
*-Je me demande
si la citation est complète,
parce que le Général de Gaulle,
il était animé par un projet,
par une ambition,
par une vision,
par un idéal,
et il pensait
que la réalité se transforme
et que le but de la politique,
c'est d'agir
pour que la réalité soit
en accord
avec vos intérêts et vos valeurs.
Et donc, oui, bien entendu,
une diplomatie doit être fondée
sur un principe de réalité,
mais une diplomatie est animée
par un gouvernement,
elle est animée
par un président de la République
en ce qui nous concerne,
elle est animée par un certain
nombre de visions et d'idéaux
et notamment la conviction
que, dans l'état actuel
de la société internationale,
il faut avoir pour mantra
la recherche de la paix,
la recherche de la justice,
la recherche d'une cohérence
entre nos actions économiques,
nos actions politiques,
nos actions militaires
et ça, dans un cadre non seulement
national, mais aussi européen.
-Alors, je vous poserai
la question autrement.
Les autres nations considèrent
que la France a
une politique de grandeur,
une politique arrogante, etc.,
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça ?
Sur les caractéristiques
de cette diplomatie ?
-Quand notre président
de la République invite
à Paris, pour un sommet
sur un nouveau pacte
financier mondial,
chefs d'Etat, dirigeants
d'institutions internationales
publiques et privées,
ils viennent.
Ils viennent parce qu'ils savent
que la France sait porter
un certain nombre d'idées,
un certain nombre de propositions,
et sait agir
sur un certain nombre de paramètres,
qui font que nous sommes considérés
comme étant capables
d'aller vers des solutions
plus inclusives, plus intéressantes,
plus pragmatiques.
Il ne s'agit pas d'avoir
une diplomatie de la grandeur,
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens,
il s'agit d'avoir
une diplomatie ambitieuse
pour construire
les éléments de la paix
et de plus de stabilité dans
un monde qui, comme vous le disiez,
est brutal, est conflictuel,
est travaillé par des tensions
extrêmement fortes.
Philippe Gélie,
qu'en pensez-vous en tant
que journaliste
et observateur privilégié
de la politique internationale ?
-Il me semble effectivement
qu'on ne peut pas
faire de diplomatie
en dehors des réalités
ou alors ça donnerait des résultats
probablement assez lunaires.
Il y a les réalités. Pour moi,
c'est un mélange de trois piliers.
Les réalités,
les principes qui sont importants
et, comme l'a dit Jérôme Bonnafont,
les ambitions, les objectifs
qu'on se fixe. Et il peut
y avoir du jeu dans la machine
entre les ambitions,
les moyens qu'on se donne,
les principes
qu'on respecte plus ou moins,
et c'est là où,
évidemment, le débat commence
sur la politique étrangère
d'un pays,
en l'occurrence, la nôtre.
-Yves Saint-Geours,
vous êtes historien également.
-Pour moi,
les choses sont assez claires.
D'abord, c'est pas parce que
les difficultés s'amoncellent
qu'il faut renoncer à essayer
de construire quelque chose.
Et c'est effectivement souvent
dans les difficultés
que des propositions
paraissent irréalistes,
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre,
et à ce moment-là,
on est taxé de tous ces adjectifs
dont il a été question.
Mais quoi, la diplomatie,
c'est quoi ? C'est des intérêts.
Un diplomate va
défendre les intérêts
de son pays.
C'est des valeurs,
évidemment.
Et tout ça, c'est des réalités,
y compris les valeurs,
c'est des réalités,
parce que les autres ont
d'autres valeurs.
Et des alliances qu'on a,
qu'on construit, qu'on fait évoluer
et qu'on met au service
des propositions qu'on fait.
Par conséquent, dans ce cadre,
moi, je considère que
certes il est tout à fait absurde
de faire des propositions en l'air
sans tenir compte
de ces réalités ou de ces intérêts,
mais que proposer, proposer encore
et avoir l'outil diplomatique
pour faire avancer les choses.
-Alain Rouquié,
vous récusez le terme d'arrogance
de la diplomatie française ?
-Oui, je le récuse totalement,
d'abord parce que cette idée
que la France est en 2e classe,
plutôt voyage en 1re classe
avec un ticket de 2e classe,
que les Américains nous lancent
à la figure très souvent,
ça ne tient pas la route.
Parce que ce n'est pas
en fonction de l'importance
économique d'un pays
qu'on peut juger de sa diplomatie.
Un pays peut avoir une diplomatie...
Et même un Etat comme le Vatican
a une diplomatie
extrêmement active et mondiale.
Ce n'est pas une comparaison,
mais enfin,
il est vrai que ça ne dépend pas
de l'étendue du territoire.
Sinon, à ce moment-là, la Russie
aurait la 1re diplomatie du monde,
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait le cas.
Je crois que
la France a
une tradition diplomatique,
quel que soit le nom
qu'on lui donne, qui a
un certain nombre de volets,
des responsabilités mondiales,
parce que nous avons un passé
et nous avons un présent
où nous sommes présents.
Dans l'Indo-Pacifique, en Afrique,
en Amérique latine
qu'on oublie trop souvent,
où nous avons
beaucoup d'intérêts économiques
et une présence culturelle
très forte.
Et la France ne fait pas mauvaise
figure étant une puissance atomique
et étant membre du Conseil
de Sécurité des Nations Unies.
Donc l'arrogance, je ne la vois pas.
La France a
comme présent et avenir l'Europe.
Elle a
le devoir de participer
à la résolution
des problèmes des conflits,
mais aussi des défis mondiaux,
des problèmes communs.
-On va en parler.
-Philippe Gélie.
-Je ne balaie pas d'un revers
de main l'accusation d'arrogance,
d'abord parce qu'elle nous est
imputée par, souvent,
nos partenaires y compris en Europe,
et pas seulement nos adversaires.
Ca n'est pas nécessairement une
critique qui n'est pas constructive.
Et ensuite, ça n'est pas
l'appareil diplomatique,
l'outil diplomatique
qui est arrogant,
ce qui est arrogant parfois,
c'est la politique étrangère
qui, en France, est décidée par
un homme et une toute petite équipe
et ensuite mise en musique
par cet outil diplomatique
riche et puissant.
Mais on fait quand même souvent
une diplomatie de coups
plus que de stratégie ou disons
que les coups ont tendance
à faire de l'ombre à la stratégie,
parce que tout ça est décidé
à l'Elysée entre 3 personnes.
-Jérôme Bonnafont, peut-être
voulez-vous répondre
aux propos de Philippe Gélie,
mais je voulais avec vous
approfondir cette question.
Avant d'être à Genève, vous avez eu
des fonctions au Quai d'Orsay.
Quand on parle
d'un projet industriel,
on parle de maître d'oeuvre
et de maître d'ouvrage.
Quand on parle
d'une action militaire,
on parle de chaîne de commandement.
Mais pour la diplomatie française,
qui décide et comment ça se passe ?
Entre le domaine
réservé présidentiel,
dont je rappelle que
ça n'est pas dans la Constitution,
le Quai d'Orsay et l'ambassadeur
qui, lui, est dépositaire
de l'autorité de l'Etat
dans le pays où il est accrédité,
comment ça fonctionne ?
En quelque sorte,
qui initie, qui décide,
comment ça se passe ?
-Il n'en va pas
différemment de la diplomatie
des autres chapitres
de l'action publique.
Il y a d'un côté un gouvernement,
qui a une légitimité démocratique
dans notre cas,
il y a à la tête de l'Etat
un chef de l'Etat,
qui est investi de pouvoirs
que la Constitution lui confère
et que la pratique institutionnelle
lui confère,
et il y a un appareil d'Etat
avec des hauts fonctionnaires,
des fonctionnaires moyens,
des fonctionnaires territoriaux,
des fonctionnaires nationaux,
qui sont chargés d'abord
d'une mission
d'expertise et de conseil,
ensuite d'une mission de mise en
oeuvre une fois la décision prise,
dans un dialogue permanent
entre la haute fonction publique
et le gouvernement. Il n'en est pas
différemment dans la diplomatie.
Ce dont le gouvernement a besoin,
c'est de diplomates
qui lui donnent de façon précise,
experte, rigoureuse,
impartiale, l'état des lieux
de la situation mondiale.
Géographique, Monsieur Rouquié
parlait de l'Amérique latine.
Il faut connaître l'Amérique latine
dans ses racines les plus profondes
pour pouvoir
porter un jugement intelligent
sur ce qui se passe
au Venezuela, au Brésil, à Cuba,
au Honduras, où nous avons
des intérêts, en Argentine, etc.
Ensuite, il faut,
sur les problèmes globaux,
le changement climatique,
la santé mondiale,
le numérique, le terrorisme,
les questions nucléaires,
il faut des gens
qui à la fois connaissent
la substance technique des questions
et en même temps connaissent la
façon dont cette substance se joue
à travers
les rapports de force mondiaux.
Et donc c'est là que se situe le
rôle du diplomate, dans l'expertise.
Ensuite, le président, la ministre,
le gouvernement décident
entourés de ces avis,
et une fois la décision prise,
la diplomatie exécute.
C'est un mécanisme
de dialogue permanent
entre les uns et les autres
et il ne faudrait pas vivre
dans un Etat
dans lequel la technocratie
l'emporterait sur le politique,
pas plus qu'il ne faudrait vivre
dans un Etat
dans lequel le politique
méprise la technocratie
et la réalité des choses
telles qu'elles vont.
-Yves Saint-Geours,
Jérôme Bonnafont dit
que c'est l'ambassadeur qui envoie
quelques notes,
si on peut... voilà et que
c'est sur ces notes-là
qu'une décision
se prépare, s'argumente, etc.
Mais est-ce qu'on est sûr
que tant au Quai d'Orsay
qu'à l'Elysée, ça fonctionne
et que les notes sont prises
en considération ?
-Il a dit un peu plus que ça.
Il a dit qu'il y avait une chaîne
qui se déploie au sein du ministère
des Affaires étrangères,
où il y a évidemment les directions
de l'administration centrale
et aussi la capacité
de collecter d'autres informations,
en interministériel ou directement,
et qu'évidemment, il y a aussi,
et on évoquait l'Amérique latine,
le plus proche du terrain,
la compréhension
de ce que sont chacun des pays,
chacun des pays, ses positions,
ses valeurs, ses principes,
ses actions. Alors,
moi, je considère que c'est
parfaitement exact. Et je considère,
peut-être au-delà même
de ce qu'a dit Jérôme Bonnafont,
que le Quai d'Orsay,
dans nos institutions
de la Ve République,
compte tenu du rôle spécifique
du président de la République
et du domaine réservé,
c'est presque
un grand cabinet du président
de la République,
qui est véritablement dédié
par à la fois ses initiatives
propres dans les ambassades
ou à l'intérieur du ministère
ou par les demandes
qui lui sont faites,
à cette expertise,
ces conseils,
ces conseils de mise en oeuvre,
ces projets,
et évidemment, des discussions aussi
là où chacun est
avec les autres.
Donc oui, je considère véritablement
qu'au-delà même des autres
départements ministériels,
on est tout à fait
dans cette ligne, et au service
d'une politique étrangère que
les diplomates ne définissent pas
directement, qu'ils mettent
en oeuvre, en musique.
Alors, à la question précise,
est-ce que toutes les notes,
est-ce que tout ça est pris
en considération ?
Bah, précisément, la question,
c'est définition d'une politique
étrangère, apport des serviteurs
de cette politique étrangère
que sont les diplomates.
Certainement que la réponse
est non, parfois,
parce qu'une ligne politique
se dégage qui ne va pas dans le sens
que va conseiller l'ambassadeur,
une politique
plus générale se fait
et c'est vrai
que, de temps en temps,
on peut être éventuellement déçu
par la décision
qui est prise
ou pas prise d'ailleurs.
-Alain Rouquié, pour aller plus
loin, je vais vous laisser répondre,
mais je voudrais préciser
cette chose-là.
Un de vos collègues,
pour ne pas le citer,
Gérard Araud, a déclaré
au cours d'une réunion que,
pour la politique
étrangère,
selon le degré de proximité
entre le ministre
des Affaires étrangères et l'Elysée,
ça fonctionnait plus ou moins bien.
C'est vrai, ça ?
-Je ne suis pas là pour interpréter
la pensée...
-Non,
mais que pensez-vous de ça,
par exemple ?
-Je pense que nous avons beaucoup de
chance par rapport à d'autres pays.
Par exemple, aucun président
de la République n'a accepté
de créer un Conseil national
de Sécurité comme aux Etats-Unis,
qui aurait marginalisé
le Quai d'Orsay.
Quand j'étais
directeur des Amériques,
c'était le conseiller
diplomatique en me disant :
"Le président a besoin d'une note
à telle heure sur tel sujet,
tu me l'envoies."
Donc la chaîne
de communication fonctionne
parfaitement.
Et, comme le disait Yves
tout à l'heure,
le Quai d'Orsay est au service
de ceux qui prennent les décisions,
c'est-à-dire de l'Elysée. Et ça,
ça me semble très bien.
Par ailleurs,
qu'il y ait de la perte en ligne,
évidemment quand on est
en poste, on fait
l'information,
la synthèse des informations,
l'interprétation des informations
et on fait des propositions
si on est
un vrai ambassadeur
qui est conscient
de ce qu'il doit faire
dans le pays
où il est. Ces propositions
ne sont pas toujours acceptées,
parce que ça ne correspond pas
à la politique du moment,
à d'autres intérêts,
intérieurs ou extérieurs,
européens ou mondiaux,
et bon, on est là pour ça.
Mais on est là pour faire des
propositions,
pas simplement pour envoyer
de l'information brute.
Et ça, je crois
que ça marche assez bien.
Il y a le filtre des cabinets,
qui est un autre problème
avec la multiplication
des cabinets qui n'existent pas
dans d'autres pays,
mais avec des directions,
géographiques ou thématiques,
ça fonctionne bien
et je crois que ça va
dans le bon sens,
à condition d'avoir des diplomates
qui soient des experts formés
et...
-On va en parler justement
de la formation.
-...la vocation
de faire bien leur métier.
-Philippe Gélie.
-Je vais être
voué à décrire le verre
à moitié vide dans cette émission,
mais il me semble que ce que décrit
monsieur, la perte en ligne,
c'est dans le cas idéal,
c'est quand tout va bien,
c'est le minimum syndical,
mais on sait bien qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'administrations,
de présidents, de gouvernements,
pas d'administrations, ça,
c'est pour les Américains,
qui ont montré
une défiance assez nette
pour les ambassadeurs en général
ou pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux
sur des sujets
particulièrement aigus.
Nicolas Sarkozy avait voulu créer
un conseil de sécurité.
-Ca n'a pas marché.
-Parce qu'il y avait
des complications
constitutionnelles,
mais il avait cette intention.
Et c'est vrai que souvent
nos présidents,
qui sont les maîtres quand même
de la politique étrangère,
peuvent reprocher aux diplomates
d'être un peu
trop près de leur sujet,
d'être du côté du manche,
de pas avoir assez de recul.
Donc ça se passe pas toujours
de manière
aussi idéale que décrite.
-Les présidents ou...
surtout les présidents
reprochent aux diplomates
leur expertise.
D'en savoir trop, de tenir compte
de plusieurs volets
d'une même situation.
"Si vous faites ça,
ça va déclencher ça."
J'ai un exemple,
la déclaration franco-mexicaine
sur le Salvador en 1982.
Quand elle est arrivée
de l'Elysée, c'était
la déclaration, la reconnaissance
de la belligérance,
du caractère de belligérant
des guérilleros. Ouh là là !
On leur a dit :
"Non, c'est pas possible.
Sinon, avec les Etats-Unis, etc."
Finalement, c'est devenu
la reconnaissance du caractère
représentatif des deux camps.
Ca sert à ça,
les expertises.
-Yves Saint-Geours.
-Ce que je dis,
ce que nous affirmons
n'est pas contradictoire
avec ce qui vient d'être dit.
Il y a des hommes et des femmes
derrière tout ça, des situations,
et de fait, il arrive
que les choses se passent
comme c'est dit,
c'est-à-dire défiance, confiance,
sur tel sujet, tentative...
Mais ça, c'est une histoire
qui est une histoire de toujours.
Ceux qui ont écrit
des livres le savent.
De diplomaties parallèles,
parce qu'effectivement, on considère
que les ambassadeurs vivent
le syndrome de Stockholm
et sont au service du pays
où ils sont accrédités.
Tout ça existe.
Mais ce qu'il faut dire,
c'est que le dispositif
tel qu'il existe,
c'est ce sur quoi j'insistais,
lui, c'est un dispositif vertueux,
c'est-à-dire qu'il est
une administration
avec une séparation,
une division du travail, qui est,
selon moi, bien faite,
avec des équilibres
qui sont pas toujours les mêmes,
parce que le ministre est
plus ou moins proche du président,
plus ou moins fort
sur un certain nombre
de sujets, etc.,
en tout cas dans l'histoire récente
de la Ve République.
Maintenant, de fait, ça marche pas
toujours formidablement.
-Jérôme Bonnafont, je voudrais
vous interroger sur un sujet
un peu polémique si on peut dire.
Le corps diplomatique français
a compté des figures illustres
parmi ses membres,
de positionnements
politiques diversifiés.
Certains sont qualifiés
d'atlantistes,
d'autres
de tiers-mondistes. Bon.
Ils proviennent de formations
distinctes. La mixité hommes-femmes,
finalement tardive,
mais est en train de se faire.
Mais, à votre avis, est-ce que
tout cela est mis en péril,
en difficulté, la pérennité
diplomatique est en cause,
avec cette réforme
de la haute fonction publique
et la disparition
du corps diplomatique
en tant que corps spécifique ?
-Alors, il n'y a pas
un corps diplomatique,
il y en avait 5.
Et il en reste un certain nombre.
-Deux essentiels.
-Ce qui a disparu, ce qui est en
voie d'extinction plus exactement,
c'est le corps des conseillers
des ministres plénipotentiaires
qui fusionne avec un grand corps
des administrateurs de l'Etat.
Et les diplomates ont pas aimé
cette réforme,
parce qu'elle leur paraissait nier
la spécificité
du métier diplomatique,
c'est-à-dire cette expertise
à la fois géographique
de civilisations et thématiques,
qui fait leur caractéristique
et ce mode de vie.
Il y a eu
les états généraux de la diplomatie
à la demande de la ministre
et du président de la République
et ce qu'a dit le président
à la fin de ces états généraux,
c'est : "Je maintiens le métier,
"je vais lui donner plus de moyens,
"mais j'en modifie
les conditions d'exécution
"en fonction de l'analyse
que je fais
"de ce que doit être
un Etat moderne."
A partir de là,
moi, ce qui me paraît important
en tant
que diplomate professionnel,
c'est que nous ayons les moyens
de faire ce métier,
un, en recevant la formation
qui est nécessaire pour le faire,
deux, en étant toujours animé
par cette espèce
d'intense curiosité du monde
qui est la marque de fabrique
du diplomate,
trois, en étant inséré dans l'Etat,
tel que l'Etat est aujourd'hui
et quatre, en évoluant
dans notre carrière
de façon à suivre
le mouvement du monde,
que ce soit dans ses technologies,
dans ses rapports de force,
dans l'émergence ou la disparition
de puissances, etc.
Et de ce point de vue, ce qui est en
train d'être accompli comme réforme
sous l'impulsion de Madame Colonna,
me semble aller dans la direction
d'une diplomatie qui sera mieux
installée dans l'Etat
et qui disposera des moyens
de compétences nécessaires
pour continuer cette mission-là.
Après,
il y aura toujours des gens
qui seront nostalgiques
du système antérieur.
Il faudra toujours veiller
à garder le professionnalisme
et la vocation qui fait
la caractéristique de ce métier.
Mais je pense,
moi, je suis optimiste
sur l'avenir des métiers
diplomatiques français.
-En somme, c'est comme si vous étiez
des journalistes
sans carte de presse ?
Vous perdez cette spécificité,
mais vous considérez
que c'est pas gênant
pour l'innovation
diplomatique et son...
-Quand le général de Gaulle et ceux
qui l'ont servi ont créé l'ENA,
ils ont créé un corps
des administrateurs civils,
qui avait vocation à rassembler
l'ensemble de la fonction publique
interministérielle.
C'est un petit peu la même chose
qui est en train de se passer.
Comment va-t-on garder la
spécificité du métier de diplomate
telle qu'elle a besoin d'être
dans un Etat ouvert sur le monde
et sur l'Europe ?
Et comment va-t-on
en même temps faire vivre
cette ouverture
à l'interministériel,
qui est plus nécessaire que jamais
compte tenu des thématiques
que la diplomatie
brasse maintenant.
Moi, je pense
que c'est un métier de vocation
et je pense que ceux qui,
dans la durée, voudront l'accomplir,
sont des gens
qui sont animés par cela et que
ceux qui ont une vague curiosité de
diplomate pendant un certain temps,
oui, occuperont des fonctions
de diplomate de temps en temps,
souvent avec talent,
mais ce ne sera pas leur vie.
Ce sera un passage.
-Qu'en pensez-vous,
Philippe Gélie ?
-Il me semble qu'on est
quand même encore dans un système
de diplomates professionnels
en France, heureusement d'ailleurs,
et qu'en dépit de cette réforme,
qui effectivement passe mal
et dont on ne saisit pas
très bien
la valeur ajoutée pour être franc,
de mettre dans un pot commun
des fonctionnaires
d'un certain grade, bon.
Ca va permettre certainement,
comme le dit Jérôme Bonnafont,
à des hauts fonctionnaires
qui viennent d'autres corps
ou d'autres administrations
de faire une incursion
dans la diplomatie.
On n'en est quand même pas
au point des Etats-Unis,
où chaque président nomme
dans les meilleurs
postes ou les postes les plus
prestigieux des ambassadeurs
qui sont en fait des contributeurs
à ses campagnes.
-Ce sont pas eux
qui portent effectivement
la diplomatie de leur pays.
-Ca dépend.
-C'est des donateurs
et voilà.
-Oui, certes,
mais une qu'ils sont
dans leur poste, ils ont quand même
toutes les tâches
de l'ambassadeur à accomplir
et parfois
avec plus ou moins de bonheur.
Donc on est nous, je pense,
toujours en France
dans un schéma
de diplomates professionnels,
en dépit
de ces petits coups de canif
aux corps diplomatiques au pluriel.
Après, il faut voir comment
sera mise en oeuvre la réforme.
Quelle ampleur prendra
la part du non-diplomate
de vocation dans l'exercice
de la diplomatie et ça,
je pense que c'est un peu tôt.
-Vous venez de voir
cette citation d'Elie Halévy :
"Sous la menace de la force armée...
Sans la menace",
pardonnez-moi, "de la force armée,
"la diplomatie n'est que
jappement de roquet."
Ca vous fait réagir,
ça ?
Yves Saint-Geours ?
-C'est-à-dire que ne pas considérer
que, dans un conflit
ou dans une négociation difficile,
pour un moment où on est
dans une politique de puissance,
quand c'est la guerre
ou la paix,
que le recours à la force est
un moyen, ça n'est pas raisonnable.
Il faut penser
au recours à la force.
Bien sûr. Quand on est dans
cette politique. Ne pas le faire,
ça n'est pas possible.
Et effectivement,
il faut de ce point de vue
être réaliste.
Alors, beaucoup d'autres personnes
l'ont dit d'une autre façon, hein.
C'est sûr qu'il faut y penser.
Alors, nous, heureusement,
il y a mille aspects
de la diplomatie qui ne sont pas
ceux-là
et qui ne préparent pas à la guerre.
Mais, de fait,
aujourd'hui plus que jamais
ou plutôt après 75 ans
en Europe de, comment dire,
de...
...de tranquillité,
ce genre de question,
ce genre de citation
revient nécessairement
à l'ordre du jour.
-Monsieur Rouquié, je voudrais
avoir votre avis là-dessus.
Si nous prenons
les grands événements du 21e siècle,
le 11 septembre 2001
avec les attentats
aux Etats-Unis,
la crise
des subprimes en 2008,
les Printemps arabes en 2011,
et plus près de nous,
la guerre en Ukraine,
qui a commencé en février 2022,
pour s'en tenir
à quelques événements comme ça,
finalement, rien n'a été prévu.
Vous voyez ça comme un échec
de la diplomatie en tant
que vigie en quelque sorte pour
anticiper les crises ? Parce que
tout ça est arrivé par hasard,
on n'a rien vu ?
-Je voudrais dire
plutôt le contraire.
Il n'appartient pas
aux diplomates
d'empêcher des attentats.
-Sans empêcher,
c'est tombé comme un tonnerre.
-Pour aller sur le sujet
que vous abordiez auparavant,
à quoi cela sert-il d'être le pays
militairement le plus fort du monde
pour ne pas avoir empêché
ces attentats, pour avoir envahi
l'Irak, ce qui n'a servi à rien,
sinon à créer
le désordre...
-Je parle
de la diplomatie en général.
-Vous parliez aussi des rapports
entre la puissance militaire
et la diplomatie.
-Absolument.
-La puissance militaire n'assure pas
une bonne diplomatie ni une bonne
organisation de la diplomatie.
La crise de l'Irak, par exemple,
il est évident
que la crise de l'Irak, la France
et l'Allemagne s'y sont opposées
avec de bonnes raisons,
ça a été une catastrophe.
-Mais ça, c'est venu
après le 11-Septembre.
Tous ces grands événements
sont arrivés là
comme...
-Le 11-Septembre, on pensait
qu'il y avait des capacités
de renseignement aux Etats-Unis
particulièrement pertinentes
et développées, c'était pas le cas.
Donc rien n'empêche
ce genre d'événements.
Et quant aux diplomates,
c'est pas à eux...
On leur a reproché
de ne pas avoir prévu
les Printemps arabes
ou ceci ou cela.
-C'est vrai.
-Ils ne sont pas là pour prévoir,
mais pour informer et proposer.
-Ils ressentent les situations.
-Oui, mais enfin,
pour ce qui est
du Printemps arabe tunisien,
les diplomates avaient ressenti.
Et le gouvernement avait dit :
"Mais non,
on appuie notre ami Ben Ali."
Et on a continué de l'appuyer.
Il faut bien voir
que les diplomates parfois
ont raison, parfois ils ont tort.
Mais souvent,
ils ont tort d'avoir raison.
Et les gouvernements,
parce qu'ils ont d'autres intérêts,
ils ont d'autres engagements,
ils ont d'autres visions
du monde, disent :
"Non, ce que vous dites là,
on peut pas l'accepter."
"Ca va exploser."
"Non, vous en faites pas."
Et on a vu à cette époque-là
pour la Tunisie du moins.
-C'est pas votre sentiment
que ça explose et après...
-Sur ce terrain,
les journalistes peuvent
être solidaires
des diplomates. On n'est pas
tellement meilleurs
pour prédire les catastrophes.
Je pense qu'avant le 11-Septembre,
un certain nombre de gens savaient
que Ben Laden existait,
que c'était quelqu'un à surveiller.
De là à dire que les événements
allaient se produire
comme ils se sont produits,
même le FBI aux Etats-Unis,
il y a un rapport de 1500 pages
du Congrès américain.
Oui, il y a eu des erreurs
humaines, des gens
qui n'ont pas connecté
les dots, comme on dit.
Franchement, c'est un peu commode
de mettre ça sur le dos
des diplomates à mon sens.
-Jérôme Bonnafont, que pensez-vous
de ce côté non anticipateur ?
Je me souviens,
pour parler de notre pays,
de la guerre en Ukraine,
deux semaines avant.
Les déclarations fort nombreuses
de certaines personnalités
politiques, militaires,
journalistes,
étaient qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'invasion de l'Ukraine.
Comment se fait-il
qu'on n'arrive pas,
non pas à prévenir,
mais au moins
à anticiper ces choses-à ?
-Oui. Deux remarques.
D'abord sur Halévy,
votre citation d'Halévy,
je pense qu'il faut l'étendre
aux rapports de force en général.
La diplomatie,
c'est en quelque sorte
la civilisation
des rapports de force.
C'est d'essayer de régler
par la négociation
des choses que
les rapports de force économiques,
culturels, sociaux, militaires,
régleraient autrement
par des moyens qui seraient brutaux
et qui seraient l'application
de la loi de la jungle.
C'est à ça que ça sert,
la diplomatie.
Deuxièmement, je voudrais faire
observer qu'il y a eu
des élections en Grèce
et des élections en Turquie
et qu'aucun des bons observateurs
les plus experts n'ont vu
à quel point
les victoires seraient nettes
dans un cas pour l'un,
dans l'autre cas pour l'autre.
Et ça, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ca veut dire qu'en réalité,
il y a un brouillard sur le présent
et sur ce qui est
en train de se préparer.
Et il y a des circonstances
exceptionnelles dans lesquelles,
par le hasard d'une clairvoyance,
le hasard
d'une information qui arrive,
vous savez précisément avant
les autres ce qui va se passer.
Mais dans la plupart des cas,
vous êtes surpris par l'accident,
vous êtes surpris par ce qui arrive
et votre mission à ce moment-là,
c'est la capacité d'adaptation
à ce qui vient de se passer.
Et je crois qu'il ne faut pas
demander au système
des choses
qu'il ne peut pas donner.
Un diplomate, pas plus qu'un
journaliste, comme vous le disiez,
n'est pas un prophète.
Un diplomate, c'est un analyste,
quelqu'un qui, par ses contacts,
par sa connaissance du terrain,
par son expertise, arrive
à essayer de décrypter
un certain nombre de choses,
mais il ne peut pas savoir lui-même
ce que les gens du pays dans lequel
il habite ne savent pas eux-mêmes.
Je crois que très peu de gens
au monde savaient
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
que le président Poutine
avait décidé d'envahir l'Ukraine.
Je crois que ce nombre se compte
de façon très, très, très restreinte
et que les Russes eux-mêmes
l'ignoraient.
Alors, pourquoi,
comment voudriez-vous plutôt
que les diplomates le sachent ?
-Oui. Qu'en pensez-vous,
Yves Saint-Geours, là-dessus ?
On est là, ça arrive et voilà,
ça tombe ? C'est pas plus
les journalistes que les diplomates,
les événements
nous tombent du ciel comme ça ?
-Ca ne se passe pas
tout à fait comme ça quand même.
-Ecoutez, regardez,
prenez ce qui se disait
en France par exemple
deux semaines avant l'invasion
de l'Ukraine, personne n'y croyait.
-On avait quand même
un président qui allait à Moscou
pour essayer de convaincre Vladimir
Poutine de ne pas envahir l'Ukraine
sur la foi des renseignements
américains très circonstanciés.
-En réalité, dans la question,
il y a une autre question,
qui est celle de savoir
si on n'essaie pas
en ne dépeignant pas complètement
une réalité qu'on redoute
de prévenir cette réalité.
Effectivement, le travail du
diplomate, c'est aussi d'essayer
de faire des propositions,
comme on le disait,
pour prévenir des situations.
De ce point de vue-là,
si... Vous voyez,
une situation, les Américains
semblent savoir que Monsieur Poutine
va envahir l'Ukraine. Bon.
Il y a une autre situation.
Le président de la République,
il va parler inlassablement
avec Monsieur Poutine
pour prévenir cela.
C'est donc qu'il craint quand même
que ça se réalise.
Ah bah oui.
-Alors, sortons
de ces prudences,
et je voudrais vous citer trois cas,
vous interviendrez, de télescopage
entre les failles diplomatiques
et des actions militaires
et avoir votre avis. Alors,
Jérôme Bonnafont, pour la première,
si nous prenons
l'attitude de Barack Obama,
les bras ballants,
réduit à l'impuissance en 2013
face au gazage
des populations en Syrie
et l'annexion qui suit
l'année d'après
par Poutine et la Russie
de la Crimée, est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a cause à effet,
un lien entre les deux ?
-Je ne crois pas que Barack Obama
soit resté les bras ballants.
Il a fait un choix politique
qu'il a expliqué d'ailleurs
longuement dans l'Atlantic Journal,
avec lequel les Français
n'étaient d'ailleurs pas d'accord,
qui est le choix de ne pas
intervenir militairement en Syrie.
Ce n'est pas une passivité, c'est
une décision de non-intervention.
Et vous vous souvenez
que la diplomatie française,
enfin, la diplomatie, pardon,
le gouvernement français
et le président de la République
étaient convaincus
qu'après l'usage d'armes chimiques
par le régime syrien,
il fallait cette réaction militaire
et les Américains,
d'ailleurs les Anglais d'abord,
puis les Américains...
-Quitus là-dessus,
mais sur le télescopage ?
Un an après, l'invasion
de la Crimée par Poutine.
Est-ce que ça vous paraît lié ?
-Il me paraît difficile de faire
du commentaire dans la position
dans laquelle je suis. Je voudrais
légèrement déporter le débat
sur quelque chose d'autre :
comment réagit-on maintenant
face à une menace nouvelle
qu'est la cybermenace
et qu'est l'ensemble
de défis nouveaux
auxquels nous sommes confrontés,
d'abord par la manipulation
de la vérité et de l'information
que permet cette nouvelle réalité
et ensuite par la capacité
technologique d'entrer
dans des systèmes et de pouvoir
les attaquer très durement ?
Et là-dessus,
ce que j'observe, c'est que,
sous l'impulsion de nos autorités,
le gouvernement dans son ensemble
et le Quai d'Orsay en particulier
sont en train de construire
de nouveaux instruments
qui vont permettre, espérons-nous,
voulons-nous, souhaitons-nous,
d'intervenir
contre la désinformation,
contre les cyberattaques,
de s'armer
face à une menace nouvelle.
Et je crois que là, il y a
une nécessité d'anticipation,
d'adaptation et de modernisation
sur laquelle il me semble que
nous devons faire porter l'accent
si nous voulons rester pertinents
face aux menaces
du monde contemporain.
-Merci, mais sur ces télescopages,
Philippe Gélie, j'aimerais
avoir votre avis
sur un autre télescopage.
L'intervention franco-britannique
en Libye
en 2011, qui aboutit
à la disparition de Kadhafi.
Et ce qui suit
dans les années après,
c'est-à-dire la dispersion
du djihadisme
en Afrique.
Est-ce que vous y voyez
un télescopage ?
Certains ont reproché
en quelque sorte d'avoir laissé
la Libye
dans un état de décomposition
avancée, avec
toutes les armes qui sont allées
se distribuer en Afrique.
C'est pour montrer un peu
cette concordance des temps.
-Oui, mais on peut
effectivement considérer
que c'est un des facteurs
qui ont peut-être contribué
à cette dispersion du djihadisme,
mais l'intervention en Libye
n'a pas inventé les djihadistes.
-Je ne dis pas ça.
-On ne peut pas réduire l'effet
à une seule cause.
-Tout à fait,
mais que pensez-vous
de ce télescopage dans le temps ?
-Ce que je viens d'en dire,
c'est-à-dire
que c'est probablement
une des causes,
certainement pas la seule,
peut-être même pas la principale.
Sur votre télescopage précédent,
c'est pareil. Je pense
que certains peuvent avoir
le sentiment qu'il y a un lien,
parce que Poutine fait
une analyse de la situation,
pensant que les Etats-Unis
n'interviendront pas, etc.
Mais si l'on veut faire
la démonstration factuelle qu'il y a
un lien de cause à effet direct
entre les deux,
c'est impossible, parce que
la vie de la planète,
c'est comme la vie tout court,
il y a toujours des facteurs
extrêmement multiples et variés.
En l'occurrence, je ne crois pas
de manière, je dirais, conceptuelle,
à des télescopages
tels que vous les décrivez
d'une cause sur un effet.
-Et vous, qu'en pensez-vous ?
Je prendrais un autre exemple
qui, lui, est
complètement actuel. On a eu
les négociations Minsk 1, Minsk 2,
le format Normandie, etc. Tout ça
laissait espérer une collaboration
entre l'Union européenne, la Russie,
Madame Merkel l'avait
initié même au niveau de l'OTAN,
etc. Et finalement,
Monsieur Poutine décide une invasion
massive, injustifiée et meurtrière
en Ukraine.
Comment vous voyez ce lien
entre les deux ?
-Je veux bien
revenir à l'Ukraine,
c'est très intéressant.
Ce qui m'a paru un des déclencheurs
de l'invasion de 2022,
c'est la passivité
des Occidentaux en 2014.
Parce que tout a commencé en 2014
et 2014 préparait l'invasion globale
et la décision
de néantiser l'Ukraine,
parce que ça avait
commencé par là.
Or la réaction a été
relativement bénigne et faible,
en disant : "Finalement,
"la Crimée, oui, cette partie,
le Donbass, bon."
S'il y avait eu une réaction
un peu plus vive,
comme après février 22, peut-être...
-Qui est responsable ?
-Les choses
se seraient passées
différemment.
-Où est
la responsabilité principale ?
-Comme tout à coup,
l'OTAN n'avait plus de valeur
pour un certain nombre
de décideurs américains,
il n'y avait pas de raison
de penser qu'il fallait
retendre les muscules
de cette organisation,
qui était quand même nécessaire
face à une violation
de la souveraineté de l'Ukraine
particulièrement caractérisée.
-Yves Saint-Geours.
-Moi, je... Je pense que
les questions posées ont trait à la
situation de la France en réalité.
-La France est pas isolée.
-Non, elle n'est pas isolée,
mais justement, justement.
-Elle a l'intention et la prétention
d'influencer la politique mondiale.
-Dans... On ne peut pas...
Justement, c'est très intéressant,
y compris ces exemples,
parce que Dieu sait
que, en Europe, depuis déjà
de nombreuses années,
les Français parlent
d'autonomie stratégique,
de capacité de l'Union européenne
à avoir une substance,
une consistance,
une robustesse politique.
Premièrement.
C'est pour ça qu'à un moment,
le président
de la République a parlé
du... de l'OTAN
et de son... comment...
Comment il a dit exactement ?
-De sa mort cérébrale.
-Sa mort cérébrale.
-Ce qui est plus le cas
aujourd'hui.
-Ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui,
mais on peut pas...
Ce qui était clair pour nous,
c'était qu'il y avait évidemment
une question à traiter qui n'avait
pas été véritablement traitée.
De même, quand on parle
du premier exemple,
bah, de nouveau,
on est dans une situation
de ce type.
La France est pas le pays
le plus puissant du monde,
on revient au début de l'émission,
même si c'est pas le plus puissant,
même s'il a des atouts, des moyens,
s'il a son rôle mondial,
et s'il est
de temps en temps, si elle est
de temps en temps
considérée comme arrogante,
dans la mesure
où elle attire l'attention
sur des éléments très importants.
Et donc, moi,
ce que je pense sincèrement,
c'est que, effectivement, on a...
c'est un concours en quelque sorte
de... de volontés
un peu européennes,
il faut bien le dire,
de continuer dans cette espèce
de long chemin de la paix
depuis 75 ans qui a fait
que la montée des périls
n'a pas été véritablement perçue
et qu'on a souvent pris
des mesures timides,
on va dire les choses comme ça.
Voilà, c'est ça, mon avis.
Et dans cette question,
il faut penser
à la politique étrangère
de la France et aux diplomates,
parce que Minsk 1, Minsk
2, toutes ces choses-là,
beaucoup de diplomates français
ont fait
une expertise, ont fait des analyses
de ces situations-là et elles
étaient pas forcément optimistes
sur l'effectivité de ce qui était
en train de se passer.
Je me souviens très bien
de tous les dispositifs qu'on a mis
en place pour essayer...
-Poutine a berné beaucoup de monde.
Jérôme Bonnafont,
je vous ai écouté sur la diplomatie
et la cybersécurité.
Est-ce que vous iriez plus loin ?
En cas de conflit,
est-ce qu'on peut avancer
vers une militarisation
de la politique étrangère,
sans aller à ce qui s'est passé
aux Etats-Unis ?
On se souvient qu'Henry Kissinger
était à la fois à un moment donné
Secrétaire d'Etat
et conseiller à la Sécurité.
Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'en période de crise,
il y a une dimension
nouvelle à prendre ?
Je me souviens
qu'il y a quelques années,
Laurent Fabius au Quai d'Orsay
avait considéré
qu'au regard
de la mondialisation arrogante,
cette fois justifiée,
il fallait que le Quai d'Orsay
prenne en considération
les échanges économiques
dans le monde.
Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'à ce niveau-là,
il y a une orientation
nouvelle à trouver ?
-Vous savez, la diplomatie
est globale.
Une diplomatie
qui serait monodirectionnelle
serait la diplomatie d'un pays
qui n'a qu'un seul rôle
dans le monde.
Or la France, elle est à la fois
une puissance européenne,
elle est un pays francophone,
elle est un membre
de l'Alliance atlantique,
elle est un pays
qui a une culture mondiale,
elle est un pays qui a des intérêts
économiques dans le monde entier,
et donc sa diplomatie par définition
doit être une diplomatie
qui embrasse l'ensemble du prisme
des relations internationales.
Premièrement.
Deuxièmement, il est certain que,
comme le disait Yves Saint-Geours,
le président de la République,
chef de l'Etat, chef des armées,
responsable premier de la paix
et de la sécurité nationale, doit
pouvoir compter
sur un appareil diplomatique
qui est parfaitement affûté
face aux menaces
telles qu'elles se présentent
à l'heure à laquelle
on a besoin d'elle.
Et par conséquent,
il est évident
que, depuis les attentats,
en particulier que nous avons connus
contre Charlie Hebdo ou le Bataclan,
on a eu une diplomatie
qui s'est énormément investie
sur toutes les questions
de sécurité antiterroriste,
dans un rôle différent de celui
des armées ou des renseignements,
mais dans un rôle d'animation
d'un renforcement de la dimension
prévention, protection, répression
du terrorisme à l'échelle mondiale.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons affaire
à un certain nombre de dirigeants
dans un certain nombre de pays
qui pensent que le recours
à la force devient, redevient
une méthode normale, banale,
de règlement des conflits.
Avec les Européens, avec l'OTAN,
à nous de démontrer
que cette voie-là est une impasse.
Et de ce point de vue,
la question de l'Ukraine est
une question absolument capitale,
parce que de la réponse qui sera
donnée, de la fin de cette guerre,
va dépendre en grande partie
l'avenir du recours à la force
dans les relations internationales
demain.
Et il est évident que,
pour un pays comme la France
et un continent comme l'Europe,
il serait catastrophique
qu'on banalise le recours à la force
et que tout ce qu'on a fait
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
pour construire l'Europe, un système
de sécurité collective, etc.,
nous conduit
à vouloir mettre en place
par une combinaison appropriée
de moyens militaires,
de moyens de renseignement,
de moyens cyber,
de moyens diplomatiques,
de capacités économiques
et financières,
un système de prévention
et de règlement des conflits.
-Nous allons conclure
là-dessus, à savoir :
est-ce qu'à votre avis,
et ce sera un peu la conclusion,
je vous laisserai à chacun 1 minute,
la guerre
en Ukraine, on sait pas
quand elle se terminera,
comment elle se terminera, etc.,
mais est-ce qu'à votre avis
dès à présent
elle a changé
les rapports de force ?
On a connu une guerre froide.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
on va vers un ordre occidental
avec des démocraties libérales
et, en face, des dictatures
ou en tout cas des régimes
autoritaires expansionnistes ?
Est-on déjà rentrés
dans cette nouvelle
phase-là ? Philippe Gélie.
-Vaste sujet.
-Oui, mais ce changement est-il
en cours aujourd'hui ?
-Bien sûr. La guerre
en Ukraine change les fondamentaux
de beaucoup de choses en Europe,
sur le continent,
sur les équilibres planétaires,
aussi la posture de la France,
qui est compliquée,
de vouloir être cette puissance
d'équilibre entre les blocs,
alors qu'il faut quand même
à un moment choisir son camp.
Et même nos alliés nous y poussent.
Donc oui, je pense
que la donne est nouvelle.
En un mot,
je dirais que le problème de
la France n'est pas sa diplomatie,
même pas du tout,
c'est beaucoup plus souvent
sa politique étrangère
qui a enchaîné pas mal d'échecs
avec Poutine, avec Xi Jinping,
avec Trump,
avec même Biden récemment
sur... l'Inflation Act.
Etc. Donc on a quand même
un diplomate en chef
qui est très, très ambitieux,
très actif, suractif,
mais qui n'a pas
la crédibilité la plus forte.
Et, à cet égard, ce que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
et je m'en tiens là, mais
le déclassement de la France
à la fois économique et militaire,
il joue dans sa crédibilité.
Il ne l'empêche pas
d'être une puissance active,
mais il entame sa crédibilité.
-En deux mots, pouvez-vous dire
quelque chose, Yves Saint-Geours ?
On a très peu de temps.
-Que l'Ukraine ait fait...
Que la guerre en Ukraine ait fait
changer les lignes, c'est clair.
Que des enjeux très, très importants
soient derrière cela,
en termes qu'expliquait très bien
Jérôme Bonnafont
sur la nécessité de construire
un dispositif de sécurité collectif
qu'en Europe, nous n'avions pas
véritablement reconstruit,
il ne faut pas l'oublier.
-On a
peu de temps.
-Quelque chose est important
dans ce que vous avez dit.
Est-ce que ça va être
"West against the rest" ?
Est-ce que ça va être l'Ouest...
-Pas l'Ouest, je dis Occident
contre les autres.
-L'Ouest, c'est-à-dire
l'Occident,
contre tous les autres ? Y a-t-il
un Sud global ? C'est
sur ces questions-là qu'il faut
travailler, la politique
étrangère française,
notamment la diplomatie,
dans un continent
que nous connaissons bien,
Alain Rouquié et moi,
l'Amérique latine,
où il y a des démocraties,
presque que des démocraties.
-Merci. Alain Rouquié,
très brièvement.
-Nous avons changé d'époque, c'est
pas uniquement la guerre en Ukraine,
il y a eu le Covid,
une certaine démondialisation,
des fragmentations mondiales,
des rêves d'empire
qui naissent ici ou là,
avec une forte conflictualité.
Il y a pas
que la Russie et la Chine,
il y a la Turquie, il y a l'Iran,
donc il faut avoir
des capacités
de prévention, de riposte
et il faut s'appuyer aussi,
je vais finir
comme mon collègue,
sur des pays démocratiques
qui partagent nos valeurs
et qu'on a oubliés beaucoup trop.
-Jérôme Bonnafont,
pour terminer, un mot.
La France est redevenue
un pays occidental
avec la guerre en Ukraine ?
-Je crois que la France doit définir
ce qu'elle veut en ayant
une sorte d'ambition pour l'avenir.
C'est-à-dire qu'il ne faut pas
regarder vers le passé,
il ne faut pas définir
le rôle de la France
par rapport à ce qu'elle a été,
il faut définir le rôle de la France
par rapport
à sa situation en Europe,
par rapport au fait que le monde
connaît une transformation énorme,
technologique,
économique, démographique,
de civilisation en quelque sorte,
et il faut toujours vouloir
que la France ait un message moderne
et optimiste pour l'avenir à porter.
Et ce message, il tient en un mot,
ça s'appelle l'humanisme,
c'est ce qui fait
notre creuset de civilisation
et c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
écoutés sur les cinq continents
avec nos forces et nos faiblesses,
mais en tout cas en étant un pays
français, pleinement français,
européen
et avec des ambitions mondiales.
-Merci, Jérôme Bonnafont.
Il me reste
à vous remercier d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Je voudrais remercier
également l'équipe de LCP, mais
avant de nous quitter, je voudrais
d'abord citer une bibliographie.
Je rappelle
de Jérôme Bonnafont,
"Diplomate,
"pour quoi faire ?"
C'est publié chez Olide Jacob.
Vous saurez tout
sur le métier de diplomate.
Je voudrais rappeler
un ouvrage de Sylvie Bermann,
"Madame l'Ambassadeur,
de Pékin à Moscou,
"une vie de diplomate".
Sylvie Bermann raconte
son itinéraire de diplomate.
Alain Rouquié,
je rappelle
que vous avez écrit
un ouvrage d'anticipation,
qui s'appelle "La fin
des diplomates", Rue de Seine.
-C'est ça, mais ce n'est pas
une anticipation
de la fin des diplomates,
il faut le lire
pour savoir.
-Il faut le lire.
Je rappelle de Maurice Vaïsse
et Yves Saint-Geours :
Un ouvrage très ambitieux où on a
un peu tous les outils, les acteurs,
depuis 1980. Ca a été publié
chez Odile Jacob. Vous avez
un livre à nous...
-Je n'ai pas
de livre à vendre.
-Et à proposer ?
-Celui de la correspondante
diplomatique du Figaro,
Isabelle Lasserre,
"Macron-Poutine :
les liaisons dangereuses".
-Ecoutez,
il me reste plus
qu'à vous remercier à nouveau
et nous terminerons
sur cette citation :
"Je crois à la victoire finale
des démocraties,
"mais à une condition,
c'est qu'elles le veuillent."
Yves Saint-Geours,
c'est de qui ?
-Ah...
-Un libéral
français.
Raymond Aron.
-Raymond Aron. Très bien.
-Ca ne pouvait être
que de Raymond Aron.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA